also bad are reports from the w-h-o
about untreatable cases of what they're
calling super bug gonorrhea saying that
we need new medications to treat the
bacterial infection a study was
published in the journal PLoS Medicine
which highlights the increased drug
resistant gonorrhea and it is being
called a serious situation so serious
that now the standard course of
treatment as per the direction of the
w-h-o to doctors is that patients should
be given two antibiotics for the STD
because of the resistance that's
emerging and this could have a major
effect on world population I mean it's
sort of Malthusian in some sense but 78
million people per year are affected
with gonorrhea women usually never show
symptoms 40% of men never show symptoms
if you don't treat it because why would
you if you have no symptoms men and
women can become infertile as well as
Rita be at extra risk of HIV from 2009
to 2014 97 percent of countries that
reported gonorrhea data say that they
found drug-resistant strains two-thirds
of countries are reporting resistance to
what's called the last resort treatment
when standard medications don't work for
many conditions you have what are called
last resort treatments for gonorrhea it
is the oral antibiotic septic cefixime
and the injectable sets react zone I
have no idea if I'm pronouncing that
right ceftriaxone and that is a major
major problem and these are there there
are strains of this that are not being
cured even with the last line last
resort medication and those have been
reported in France Japan and Spain
what's contributing to drug resistance
it's a few different things decrease
condom use more urbanization in other
words more people living closer together
more travel which allows for people
spreading the disease a greater distance
as well as lower detection rates and
improper or failed treatment
and what is also concerning is that
there are still people according to the
data that we have that are not taking
the full course of antibiotics and it is
so prevalent at that people think fine I
got 14 days of antibiotics if I feel
better after 6 days I'll not take the
rest it's common that if the antibiotic
works that you feel better after 6 days
you're given 14 days for a reason and
not taking the full dose can actually
allow the bacteria to become resistant
well I think there's also just people
out there who are against antibiotics
against contraception and just push for
abstinence only education because of
course if you just tell people not to
have sex they won't do it and the
diseases won't spread yeah and of course
as we know the reality is that when you
do that type of sex education people are
just engaging in riskier versions of the
same behavior that they might otherwise
be engaging in and it is a really really
bad idea and also completely
counterproductive take all the pills
number one and number two you've got a
you the entire abstinence only thing
it's failed on every level at this point
resident I mean there's no level on
which it's been successful it doesn't
reduce pregnancy it doesn't reduce
transmission of STDs it doesn't reduce
abortions because when people get
pregnant pregnancy is the number one
common thread among people who obtain
abortions and if you have more
pregnancies by definition you're going
to have more people seeking abortions
it's like trying to solve by obesity by
telling people not to eat I like that no
explanation I've never heard that one
before but I think it makes a lot of
sense I'm thrilled to tell you that
today's episode of the show is made
possible in part by taga dab the hosting
specialists offering dedicated virtual
private and cloud server solutions as
well as custom server solutions for
whatever business or project you have
CagA dabs web hosting services support a
very wide range of customers and
businesses that includes bloggers tech
startups financial traders gamers web
developers it's a very very long list
they've got a user-friendly interface
they have absolutely fantastic technical
support over 70% of their business comes
from repeat orders and recommendation
from existing customers you can get a 20
British Pound discount off of a cloud
server account with taga Deb but you've
got to know how to access that and the
way you access it is by going to sign up
taga Deb comm /t DPS and using the
coupon code TDPS
20 this is a great way to get great
hosting for your project business or
service and support the David Pakman
show and support our advertisers that
sign up tag adapt calm slashed edps
that's ta ga da bee and then the
discount code is TDPS 20